I asked my doctor to run a homocysteine test with my last blood work and they refused.
Why would they refused?
And what is it for?
Okay, so homocysteine, what I take a person off methyl groups.
So they were on methyl groups before they started with me, especially.
Now there's other indications too, and I'll talk about those.
So let's take a step back.
What is homocysteine?
Homocysteine is the tabolite of, so in your metabolism process you take folate and you break
it down into a chemical called methyl tetrahedral folate.
Now that goes into the methyd, what's called the methydine cycle, and you make homocysteine.
And from homocysteine, homocysteine serves a function, basically the only function that
it serves is it's an intermediate metamolite.
Now that breaks down through a gene called your CBS gene into system ethylite and it breaks
down into cyst eaters and breaks down ultimately to help with your glutathione pathway, help
with detoxification pathways, help with a lot of different things.
So remember, what an intermediate metamolite is.
Let's say your body needs to take substance A that you consume and you eat, and it has
to make substance E. So let's take it substance A and it has to convert it into substance E,
but it has to convert substance A into substance B first and then C and then D and then E.
So we're looking for more E in order to do a process of detoxification, let's say.
But the BCD are what are called intermediate metamolites.
So we could have excess B because the breakdown from B to C is being hindered from a genetic
standpoint or from a there's needed cofactors to break B down to C. So we have excess B in
our body.
Well, homocysteine is an intermediate metamolite that has to break down into other things
to help with detoxification.
If we have excess homocysteine, it can do damage to our body.
So excess homocysteine is one of the primary factors that damages our arteries.
So it scratches or etches is the correct term.
It etches the endothelial cells, the endothelial cells are the cells that line the arteries.
Homocysteine etches endothelial cells which then cause cholesterol to plaque them.
So why do we get cholesterol plaques because we have too much cholesterol?
No, it's because you have scratches, you have damage to the endothelial cells.
Not how we only cause my homocysteine but homocysteine is the main component.
So why wouldn't you run a homocysteine panel on someone when you're doing blood test?
Okay, well, if you already ran one last year and it's all normal and they don't have
any other, they don't have elevated triglycerides or cholesterol or LDL cholesterol or any other
factors of coronary disease, then you don't need to run it every three months or something.
Maybe you just run it every year.
So why would I ask for a homocysteine test?
Number one, if I looked at a person's past blood test and they never had it run, I
often say let's get a homocysteine with that too, just to make sure.
Number two, I'm dealing with cancer patients and most cancer patients, I take them off methyl
groups.
Well, methyl groups are do a lot of bad things, but they do a lot of good things too.
Remember, nothing's all bad and nothing's all good.
Homocysteine isn't all bad.
You have to have some of it because you have to break it down to the other thing, the next
thing.
So it's having an intermediate metabolite is it bad?
It's just having too much of that is bad.
So methyl groups, what is the processes of methyl groups that breaks down a homocysteine
through the CBS gene to systemethiety?
So if I took cancer patient off methyl groups and they never had a homocysteine level, it
concerns me sometimes that let's get a homocysteine level because their homocysteine levels can
go way up.
And we don't want the person to die of a heart attack while we're curing them from cancer.
So I just don't understand why a doctor would even argue the fact, even if they didn't know
anything about what I just said, they should know that homocysteine is a factor in coronary
heart disease that one might want to check once in a while.
Good as such as bothers me that these medical doctors are sitting in facilities that are
multi-million dollar facilities with all this laboratory equipment and all this testing equipment
at their fingertips and they don't use it and they don't even know who to use it sometimes.
Not all of them, but lots of them.
It's like, why would you even ask the question, why do they want a homocysteine test?
Well, don't you know what a homocysteine test is for?
I just don't get it.
Sorry, it just bothers me sometimes, but I just don't understand why they would ask that
question.
Well, sure, we'll do a homocysteine test.
That would be a good idea.
I see that you haven't had one done here.
I don't even see one in your file.
That's all that to see.
What's going on?
What it takes?
How much does it cost?
15 dollars?
You run a homocysteine test?
Add it on?
Holly, jeepers.
Sometimes it's like you're asking them for like a gold bar or something.
You're drawing by blood anyhow.
Could you run a few tests that could give us some data?
I just, it's just, sorry, nevermind.